hello there watching the press preview a
first look at what is on the front pages
as they arrive time to see them what is
making the headlines with the consultant
editor of the daily mail andrew pearce
and the associate editor of the daily
mirror kevin mcguire super to see you
both with us for a long time tonight
obviously i just performed midnight
updating you though on the front pages
first and amid revolt in the
conservative ranks of allegations of
sleaze the eye has the headline pm under
siege from his own party
the telegraph quotes boris johnson
apparently ruining his actions in the
owen patterson affair on a clear road i
crashed the car into a ditch
according to the guardian new government
proposals could see tens of thousands of
poorer pensioners paying the same as
their wealthier counterparts for care
the daily mirror speaks to a security
guard who came to the rescue of cab
driver david perry after the liverpool
taxi explosion
darren knowles said perry told him
someone has blown me up
the metro reports on the jail sentences
handed down to nine insulate britain
protesters who disrupted rush hour
traffic the times reports on a new
proposal by ministers for channel
crossing migrants to be flown out to
albania
the times financial times rather leads
with amazon's announcement that from
january it will no longer accept visa
credit cards issued in the uk though it
will still take their debit cards
and the sun claims to have details
concerning the love life of the england
footballer jack grealish
so let's talk to andrew pearce and kevin
mcguire and the telegraph with the the
quote perhaps of the night as we heard
there on a clear road i crashed the car
into a ditch andrew um a super own goal
really from the prime minister and his
team over the owen patterson stuff
yeah this is in it it supposed to use my
catholic analogy this is like a very
public act of contrition from boris
johnson he's this is probably the
biggest mistake he's made in terms of
party management in terms of misjudging
the mood of the country misjudging the
mood of parliament and critically
misjudging the mood of his parliamentary
party let alone the party in the country
and when he spoke today in the commons
the primes his questions and there was
the vote on whether they should um uh
have a new system for second jobs
there was hardly any mps toy mps on the
tory benches they were conspicuously
deserted now normally on a wednesday the
commons is still pretty busy because we
have primes as questions it was a way of
mps showing they were voting with their
feet so when he went behind the scenes
to the 1922 committee of backbench mps
he threw himself
at their mercy and said it was an open
road and he managed to drive the car
into a ditch that's exactly what he did
it's been a hugely uh uh damaging
experience for the conservative party
for him personally uh i don't think it
will be terminal because i don't think
the next election will be won or lost on
this it'll be much more to do i think
with the cost of living and maybe the
fact that this conservative government
has put taxation up to levels not seen
for 70 odd years but boris has had to
eat humble pie it's the closest he's
come to saying sorry over all of this
uh and it's a real lesson learned
because some of the mps who are most
furious with him are the ones who got
elected at the last election 2019 some
of those who owe their jobs to him
because they were their mps in the
so-called red wall seats in the north of
england but that loyalty that gratitude
doesn't last forever and they are pretty
furious that they were ordered to vote
for this ridiculous plan to save owen
patterson who broke every rule in the
mp's book by lobbying for money or met
for private companies and then talking
to ministers so this has been a really
bruising experience of boris and his
leadership is badly damaged and it will
take quite a while for it to recover
yeah the eye to kevin pm under siege
because the sum total of this ditched
car is that first of all some of your
mps might lose their lucrative jobs
secondly the sleaze tag is once again
given to your party and the polling i
mean it may well be cost of living but
the polls are certainly not looking as
rosy as the as they were before this all
started for your party
yeah i think that's right anna and that
crushed car in the ditch it's going to
take a long time for him to get it out
if indeed he can because i think respect
is gone
he's crushed respect uh doesn't mean
he's gonna be
toppled tomorrow this year even next
year but they no longer respect him they
saw him as a winner but the way he's
behaved is as a loser because he spent
two weeks uh
stoke in a sleaze row which was totally
unnecessary and again he can apologize
like that but
the problem is he set completely the
wrong political backdrop at the start of
what's going to be an incredibly tough
winter and probably year for the
conservative party as andrew just said
taxes are going to go up
prices are rising standards of living
are going to be squeezed and when you've
got that financial economic crisis
people are feeling it in their in their
pockets and their bank accounts and then
you have a sleaze scandal where it looks
as if you're
defending indeed he was in a way
defending behavior that other people
would consider totally reprehensible
he's really made a rod for um for his
own back and for the back of the the
conservative party and it was noticeable
today promises questions very few tory
mps on those benches to cheer him uh the
i say the conservative party whips the
government whips were having to ring up
uh mps to get them to go in the chamber
be there for debates they didn't want to
do it there was a queue of mps outside
his office door in the house of commons
clearly wanting to complain and then at
the 1922 committee that's the meeting of
back benchers he is had to really he's
begging for their forgiveness whether he
can get it or not is a as an open
question but he he has just scored
the most spectacular own goal uh
certainly uh certainly it's since 19
sorry at 2010 i i think you'd probably
the only comparison you could possibly
make is the general election in 2007
that never was when gordon brown toyed
with it then then didn't call for it yes
and um
the telegraph reminding us that actually
for the first time he accepted that owen
patterson the former tory mp had broken
lobbying rules is it any excuse for him
that from the liaison committee this
afternoon it was quite clear that he had
so much sympathy for mr patterson that
that may well have been what was driving
his decision-making on this yeah look i
i wrote about this extensively in the
mail last week and i got really good
background advice on what was going on
here look the reporting to owen
patterson's conduct was 179 pages he's
the prime minister he can't read
everything but he could have read a
summary or he could have asked some very
trusted lieutenants tell me what really
happened but he relied on jacob
rees-mogg the leader of the commons the
chief whip a man called mark spencer to
tell him they said that he'd been
stitched up by the parliamentary
commissioner catherine stone oh yes
that's the woman who stitched me up over
my holiday i was at the maldives or
mauritius the one he didn't pay for not
saying he should pay for them tony blair
never paid for his holidays uh and they
were always very lucrative but um so he
was too easy to accept that owen
patterson hadn't broken the rules too
easy to blame the parliamentary
commissioner who he obviously thinks of
some lefty which he may be but also as
jacob rees-mogg said he was blinded by
the fact owen patterson's wife had taken
her own life and he thought the man had
suffered enough yes he has suffered a
lot it's a terrible thing suicide it's
been awful for owen and his family but
that didn't change the fact he'd made an
egregious breach of the rules that's
what that committee said an egregious
breach of the rules there were 14
members of that committee uh
seven of them mp seven of them laid
members they all agreed one tory mp uh
recused himself but they all agreed he'd
broken the rules so you can't then
change the entire system of regulating
the commons to protect an mp who'd
flipping broken the rules
i think the problem though here uh anna
is he breaks the rules himself so often
boris johnson he revels in breaking the
rules he's the rule breaker he tried to
make it part of his uh appeal and i
think that's why he instinctively was
against the authority of the standards
commissioner i think it's unfair
actually if andrew characteristically
unfair perhaps to do nudge knowledge
wink wink catherine stone the
parliamentary standards commissioner
might be a bit of a lefty labour mps
who've been on the end of a report
including keith vaz don't think uh don't
don't think that look she she's a she is
a very skilled dedicated public servant
who goes after the truth and there are
more tory mps and labour mps at the
moment so you're going to get more of
them anyway just
statistically if more of them have got
outside interests which they have you'll
pick up more of them that way too like
she does a job
yeah look at him
apologize
listen i wouldn't mention keith vaz in
the same sentence of somebody fighting
against national justice he has was
always being done by the commons and
what was it keith who got done by the
parliamentary commissioner or was it the
washing machine salesman that he was
salesman who um was consorting with male
prostitutes and apparently hard hard
drugs as well not exactly because
i'm going to move on we've got so much
to pack in tonight honestly your list is
too long to continue if you don't mind i
want to move on to what else happened at
the liaison committee which is in the
metro uh which is quite a lot about
violence against women and girls not
least from the woman who had accused
boris johnson's father
um
who wants to pick that one up
yeah well i will correct caroline milks
who um didn't directly raise it but she
did challenge the prime minister on
whether there were
was a need is a need for stronger new
tougher laws to protect women from all
sorts of uh violence and uh and
intimidation the prime minister resisted
that so it should be the enforcement of
existing laws but there is no there's no
doubt and she she chairs the the women's
committee in the in the house of commons
she's made these uh allegations against
uh stanley johnson that he uh he
inappropriately touched her uh slapped
her bottom uh and made a joke about her
rumsey uh constituency well two other
journalists
have come forward and made allegations
too one from the new statesman that she
was groped 2019 and a third journalist
said he was very handsy now he's he said
in the inches of fairness uh stanley
johnson that he had no recollection of
uh of caroline uh caroline knox uh um
the new statesman journalist he he would
have uh said he doesn't recollect the
the moment uh and uh we don't know about
the third one but this is incredibly
embarrassing for the prime minister who
let's not forget how to grow up in
allegation against himself made by
another journalist uh charlotte edwards
which was was just dismissed by number
10 uh
at the time it's very unseemly but there
is a there's a real the real point here
and i think i know it's made it pretty
uh forcefully and uh very very fairly
it's for too long
women have had to put up uh with
inappropriate behavior from some men and
it's it's time it's uh it stops and
maybe
if it was uh
more of a more of a crime if the
authority okay kevin
and your men will behave like that yeah
we're running over i've got so much to
pack in i do apologize for cutting you
both off this evening pledging myself to
come we'll talk about inflation also new
advice related to children's cover jabs
lots more.com
[Music]
welcome back to watching the press
preview with me now andrew pierce and
kevin mcguire welcome back to both of
you um so uh quick one we got lowe's to
back in inflation kevin 4.2 highest in
10 years
now absolutely sure from 3.1 percent uh
it's why the sleazer row actually
matters because people are going to
really feel this be hit in the pocket
it's rising fuel prices uh primarily um
but who's getting pay rises more than
that nurses got three percent that's
four point two percent inflation that is
going to mean for many people an actual
real drop in their living standards and
when taxes go up national insurance uh
next year income tax thresholds frozen
this is why there is going to be a
backlash against
the government because it may go even
higher than 4.2 percent uh and daily
mail leading on this to 2000 pounds the
paper says cost of living shock the grim
forecast for a hike in your bills as in
fl why are you laughing oh i see where
they're laughing
look at that top look at the top
i think it says i've got a six-pack i
think it's more like a two-pack is that
photoshopped is that actually you no it
is not photoshopped kevin's just jealous
if you haven't got a six-pack you've got
a party seven i mean
did we ask what you're doing this is
going to cause a stir in the morning
when people have their snap crackle and
pop in the morning and see my half naked
body in the newspaper
yeah and well
use the engines they're gonna have to
put the mail on the top shelf
no no then mail it was sold out there'll
be a stampede
stampede and andrew um the mail making
its own news because the editor is uh
changing we here
yes thank you for mentioning that anna
yes georgie greg is going after three
years he's being replaced by ted verity
who's editor of the mail on sunday he's
going to be editor-in-chief of both
titles he's a very fine journalist uh
and um
we wish jordy greg very well he's had
three great years he's made it paper of
the year three times i think uh and he's
been a great campaigner and you move on
to other great pastures new they didn't
ask me to be his replacement anna just
in case you wondered well they might now
after that photograph
and for the recorder
um
just uh if you don't mind we'll just do
the final story uh which was in the
daily telegraph which we teased children
told to wait three months after kovid to
get a jab children who've had covid
should wait three months to be
vaccinated now certainly some teenagers
had already been told this andrew just
in 10 seconds tell us more yeah it it
will cause a stir because they're saying
if 12 to 15 year olds have had curvy
don't have the jab the vaccine for three
months because of that very very slim
outside chance there could be it could
cause some minor effect to the heart but
very minimal
very minimal risk andrew six pack pierce
and kevin mcguire thank you both see you
soon